OK, welcome back to another VC
libraries Open code review.
I'm Stefan T Lawhead and still maintainer.
And today we'll be looking at a PR that
will convert template metaprogramming in
our ratio header to constexpr functions.
So as usual, starting off looking at our
repo and I'll show you how we track work.
I'll go to projects.
We use a code reviews project.
These are all of the PR's.
That are awesome contributors
have submitted for our review,
so I'll just make that full screen.
They go through multiple stages of review.
The one we're looking at today
is in initial review state,
meaning that maintainer needs to look at it.
Once approved they move to final review
and once 2 maintainers have reviewed
a PR it moves to ready to merge.
This is a good way to catch issues
before they get merged into the repo.
I'm going to help educate all the
maintainers as to what's changing
in the code base because.
One of the most important things we
do over the long term is spreading
knowledge about how the code base works
amongst uh both maintainers and contributors.
So here's a PR.
I'm opened by Sam 20908,
so I will look at this PR.
This is once it loads 2450 ratio.
Use constexpr functions instead of TMPS
template metaprograms and this fix is
an issue we had filed labeled as throughput.
We may want to relabel the PR.
We like to have the issues,
uh, match the PR's.
In fact,
I'll probably go ahead and do that.
This is a suggestion,
um,
possible enhancement that our contributor
Alex Soutenu V filed back in October
and he observed that we use particular
style of code in our ratio header.
So I'll be going over how this works.
It's written with struct template
metaprogramming and we now have
constexpr functions that are in general.
More readable, Umm.
And possibly higher throughput.
Uh, throughput meaning um,
speed of compilation,
um.
Although it remains to be seen whether um,
context or functions will actually have
the promised throughput improvements,
but in theory they should because
they're just functions compared
to instantiating lots of structs.
One of the fun things we get to do
as library implementers is after
we write all of the code that
the standard forces us to write.
We add it to the headers and
then users complain.
Um, they say, hey, you know,
we were just compiling our code,
and then we upgraded and we didn't
start doing anything differently.
But now our compilations are slower.
And it's because the standard told us
to add a bunch of code to the headers.
And if the user is compiling in a
sufficiently new standard version,
well,
then all their headers gain
extra code and it's slower,
and they're now paying a cost
for benefits that they're
not yet taking advantage of.
So that's kind of sad because we can't
do a lot about that when the standard.
Requires us to add code.
We do have mitigations like we only
enable code in new standards modes.
Um, so if you remain compiling in C
+ 17 mode, you're not going to see
all the C + 20 stuff in general.
But if you are compiling with the newer
standard mode switches or C Plus latest,
as we add new code to the header,
stuff gets slower.
Partially this is compensated for by.
We find ways to make the libraries faster
to compile through issues like this one.
The compiler itself also
implements lots of optimizations,
and in general computers get
faster over time usually.
So it's sort of, uh, we win some,
we lose some when it comes to throughput.
So hopefully here we'll be getting
some throughput improvements.
Another reason to do this,
even aside from the throughput,
is readability.
This struct template metaprogramming
technique is not the most readable.
So before we get into the PR itself,
I'd like to cover exactly
what we were doing in ratio,
why we're doing it this way,
and then we'll take a look at the
actual code and see if this is
preserving correctness and hopefully
gonna have some of the readability
improvements that we're hoping for.
So let me open up our repo.
Here we go.
I've got everything, uh checked out here.
Let's uh look at the ratio header.
OK uh, I've just opened up um our OS repo.
Umm.
In VS code is workspace,
so I can hit control P and
type in any file name.
It'll take me there.
So here's the ratio header and
I can also open up the standards
that this corresponds to.
You could also look at CPP
reference if you wanted.
So if you weren't aware, uh,
we have covered it in um,
some previous code review videos.
Um C plus and C + 11 has had
headers called ratio and chrono.
Chrono actually contains a units library.
The the units are only for time,
though it would be nice in the
future to see it extended to other
units like meters and kilograms.
But just having units for time is still
plenty powerful because one of the
things it can do is have units like seconds,
milliseconds, nanoseconds.
That are convertible.
Um, and this is embedded in the type system,
so you don't need to just have like a raw
like 1500 representing 1500 milliseconds.
You can actually put that in a variable
of type stood chrono milliseconds.
And if I could find duration,
no,
I think it's in the header synopsis trying
to remember where everything is specified.
Here we go.
There's some convenience type depths,
so in the Chrono header a type like stood
Chrono nanoseconds is a stood chrono.
Operation templated on some signed integer.
It's actually long long
in our implementation,
and then something called stood nano.
So you might ask, OK,
well what's a stood nano?
That comes from the ratio header,
which is specified in clause 20
General utilities library compile
time rational arithmetic header ratio.
So this is a header in the C plus standard
that you could use directly if you wanted,
but in practice it's generally used through
the kernel header and this encodes a compile.
Time ratio as template non type arguments,
meaning here just integers to a
otherwise empty struct or class.
So here if you have ratio of something
like 5 comma seven that encodes 5
sevenths 5 sevenths in the type system
and the ratio of like stood Millie.
There's some type defs down
here is a ratio of 1 / 1000.
So the formatting looks strange
because the standard has tried
to line these up pretty nicely.
I'm not sure exactly how much that buys
and so a ratio of nano is 1 / a billion.
And this allows us to do things using
these helper variable templates and
structs like ask or two ratios equal.
Can we multiply 2 ratios?
Can we divide them and add and subtract them?
And these are needed when we
do things like conversions,
so when we convert between Chrono durations.
For example,
if you want to convert from uh let's
say microseconds um to milliseconds.
Actually, let's do it the other way around.
Suppose I want to convert um 5
milliseconds to microseconds.
I should get 5000 microseconds um.
So I gain a factor of 1000 and
we get that by using ratio.
I believe it's divide we can divide.
Let's trying to avoid trying to think
fast to avoid getting things flipped.
If we divide Millie by micro,
then we'll get the value 1000.
Saying that there are 1000 micros in
a milli and then that's how much to
multiply our stored number of milliseconds
by in order to get microseconds.
So we get the type system to perform
all of the conversions for us.
I mean it all compiles away so we
don't pay any runtime overheads,
but we get compile time type safety and
then we can do things like the kernel
library was designed by Howard Hinnant,
the proposer of the original library.
Um, such that we enable conversions and
Chrono only when they don't lose information.
So you can losslessly convert something
like seconds to milliseconds.
If you have 5 seconds,
that's 5000 milliseconds.
But we do not implicitly convert
the other way around.
If you have 1500 milliseconds,
if you try to convert that to
an integer number of seconds,
that would be 1.5.
But we would lose that .5 as an
integer that would lose information.
So we don't allow that sort
of implicit conversion.
You have to either do so explicitly
saying I want to truncate,
I want to round, floor, seal,
we have all those helpers now um or um
you have to use a different type like.
Duration using double if you
want floating point durations,
which have their own hazards,
but that's a topic for another.
Code review.
Uh, uh, we'll,
we'll talk about floating point plenty.
Um, so with ratio um,
how do we implement all that multiply,
divide, add, subtract stuff.
Let me switch over back to VS code.
So in our implementation what it looks
like is ratio is templated on NX&amp;X.
As an aside, we.
Uglify as we call it our internal
identifiers to avoid being,
um, stomped on by macros or
conflicting with user code.
So names of the form under score capital
are reserved for the compiler and library.
We conventionally avoid names of
the form under score followed by a
single letters like under score N
This looks too much like a macro,
so even though we are permitted to use it,
we add an extra letter.
So that's why you see an X purely
an internal STL convention.
Other implementations might say
something like double under score.
Uh, because that's also reserved
for the library.
But uh,
we used under score capital generally,
so that's why you see this sort of
ugly code here when when you've been
either maintaining or contributing
library for a long enough,
you're brain just starts to ignore
all those under score capitals.
And it actually lets you see what
things are intended to be usable by
users versus for internal use only.
And then when we need to implement
things required by the standard,
for example, the standard says OK,
ratio can be templated on a
numerator and a denominator.
But there's nothing stopping the user
from asking something like um 10 / 20 um.
But the standard requires that
ratio is nested, um,
static constexpr Max T NUM,
meaning numerator be reduced.
So this needs to be a reduced sort of
normalized or canonical form of the ratio.
So we need to compute that and we
do so at compile time using some of
our compile time technology here.
Right now I'm looking at the
repos main branch and not the PR.
So we've got some logic that
deals with the signs because.
The standard requires us to Umm.
I believe if the denominator is
negative we need to move that
negative into the numerator.
I'm speaking from memory that I could
check the standard itself and we
also need to reduce the fraction.
So if you go remember your math lessons,
we can reduce fractions by taking the
greatest common divisor and if we
have 10 / 20 the GCD of those is 10,
so we can divide both of them
would get 1 / 2.
O.
We implemented in our current repo
the greatest common divisor with
a struct and the reason why we
did that is we implemented this.
Trying to think back this.
The Chrono appeared in C + 11,
which is also when Constexpr appeared.
But in C + 11 constexpr is highly limited.
It was possible to write things,
but you could only have a single statement,
so it made it very difficult to
write most complicated functions.
It wasn't until Cplus fourteens
extended constexpr,
which we now just think of as
playing constexpr functions,
that it became possible to have things
like temporary variables and multiple
statements in context for functions,
which actually makes it a lot
more usable context grown.
Dramatically in power over the years?
Um. So when Chrono first appeared,
um, we weren't yet really able to use
constexpr functions for a lot of things,
so we continued using the
original classic technique.
Usable all the way back to C + 98 of having
structs do template metaprogramming.
Not because we liked using structs,
but because it was the only
way to get things done.
So here we have a helper struct,
and this is all internal because it's
you can see it's all ugly names,
so this will compute the
greatest common divisor.
Using the classic Euclidean algorithm,
we've got some special cases or base
cases for what if one of the values is 0?
And we can use the modulo operator
on the non type template arguments.
So this is how we had
implemented GCD originally.
These names here maybe
not the clearest names,
but we have an internal helper GCD X
that is then used by the more public but
still internal under score GCD struct.
Here we've got some additional extra
things happening here and this will be
relevant to the PR as we're looking at it.
Sometimes we need to forbid
overflow so in some cases.
We need to add together um,
uh values at compile time,
but we don't want them to overflow,
so we actually enforce
this using a static assert.
We have a struct that takes an A
and A/B to add and then we pass it
to an internal helper safe add X.
And here what we say is if the
signs are different,
that means we're adding negative
to positive or vice versa.
So that can never overflow,
because no matter how extreme the values are,
adding a negative to a positive
or non zero um,
can only bring them closer together to 0,
so it's definitely not going to overflow.
But if they're both negative
or both positive,
we need to worry about overflow
or going to negative.
Also consider that an overflow.
So instead of actually performing such
an addition and then discovering oops,
it overflowed,
which would be undefined behavior,
we ask without overflowing
if they would overflow.
So we have to phrase it in
a very specific way.
The absolute value of 1 is less than
or equal int Max minus the absolute
value of the other um and then uh.
Here in safe add X only if.
We can determine that the
uh operation will overflow.
Um, will we actually perform that plus?
But if we see that the signs
are not different false,
and that the addition is not safe false,
then we can detect through a struct
template partial specialization
that the addition would overflow.
That's what this comment here is saying.
And then we can simply static assert.
As an aside,
instead of simply saying static assert false,
we can't do that. Because, uh,
for the arcane and kind of annoying
reason that if we said Static cert false,
the compiler would be perfectly justified
according to the standard in saying as
soon as it sees that template definition,
oh, you've got a static assert false
there that can't possibly compile.
I will reject that on site without
even caring what A&amp;B could be here.
We only want the static assert to
terminate the compilation if this
thing is actually instantiated,
so we need to sort of delay
evaluation of the condition.
We've got this helper always false.
That is a variable template.
Unsurprisingly, is always false.
But the compiler doesn't know that.
Um, that we never bother bother
specializing this to have any other value.
So if we phrase it as static assert,
always false,
and then give it some template argument,
in this case the struct itself,
the compiler will only activate
the static assert when this
template is actually instantiated.
And then we say integer arithmetic overflow.
So this is how we basically
do an if and then terminate,
but in struct template metaprogramming.
Sometimes Umm instead of terminating
um we want to um trigger sphene,
meaning that um in Chrono we are
required and some points to make a
conversion disappear if it would overflow
rather than emitting a hard error.
So we do not want a static cert all the
time and that's why we have this bool here.
If we pass false then it will
trigger an error, but if we pass.
True it,
we're saying we need this for
the purposes of sphene um.
Instead,
we'll harmlessly absorb this
attempted overflow and we just won't
produce an integral constant answer.
And then that will go off in sphene.
So this is a very arcane
implementation detail,
but it is needed for the purposes of Chrono.
It's not exposed in the ratio library itself,
which is why this is purely internal.
There's no way using the ratio public
interface to do something like I want
to multiply or divide these two ratios,
but if it would.
Integer overflow? Don't do it.
Just not have a type def at all.
Um, arguably,
perhaps that should be publicly available,
but it's not.
So we need to implement that,
but only internally.
So this is what I'm template
metaprogramming in,
in the form of structure look like.
We're sort of encoding things like if
statements and terminates and conditions,
but they all have to be phrased as
things like partial specializations,
explicit specializations,
default template arguments.
And this is not very readable.
I mean,
I've been doing this for over 10 years and
I in fact I wrote some of this code here.
And even then I need to look at it
and then think really hard about,
OK, exactly what you know.
Are we doing here?
Um,
what are all the possible I'm conditions?
We're detecting exactly which
things get instantiated.
It's a lot of work
in comparison to constexpr functions,
because when you write a constexpr function,
you get to read and write ordinary
C code with if statements and local
variables and all that good stuff.
So now that we have the full power
of CPUs 14 constexpr and beyond,
C + 14 being the lowest supported
standard mode that we have.
Uh, this enhancement issue is
about converting this old codes
over to something more modern.
Um, but preserving all of the stuff we
have here about defending against overflow,
spinning when necessary, and so forth.
So that's the background there.
Now let's actually take a look at the PR.
So here is PR 2450,
a lot of background for only 30 added lines,
27 removed or edited.
So let's take a look at the files.
I'm going to Alt Click to minimize.
So these are changes only
to the product code,
Chrono and ratio not changing any of
the tests under the theory that the test
should already have sufficient coverage.
I believe they do.
We added,
I believe pretty good coverage of the
Kronos Phenax and I think we've got.
Um, some coverage of the ratios
we could actually look uh,
one nice things about having the
STL in Workspace is I can just do
things like search for ratio and ask.
I only want to look at our tests so I
can say, Umm, tests and then we have stood.
And that's getting corporation,
which is hilarious.
So I could ask for whole word,
or I could use a regex to look at boundaries.
OK, so we've got a test.
This was a test for a regression
test for bug.
It was in our old internal bug database.
That's the number.
But we've got tester, exercising,
ratio, add, subtract, multiply, divide.
Make sure they're equal or not equal.
Let's make sure that the ratios are reduced.
Um, uh.
In some specific cases,
like ratio add um,
we need to return a fully produced answer.
Um.
So we've got static certs for all of these,
so this is some good coverage.
All the uses of Chrono are also
covering this.
Including our calendars and time zones,
the new tests that we've got.
So I believe that the test coverage
here is good.
Certainly if we find deficient test coverage,
we can always add it in the future.
But for this PR, I'm OK with it
being product code changes only.
Unless I see something that
looks very concerning,
then I might want to go verify that,
OK, we have test coverage for this.
OK,
so now let's take a look
at what's going on here.
The changes to kronor small,
we had a least common multiple helper that's
being converted to a constexpr function.
And then being used in the common type.
OK, but that uses the GCD function
that's being added in ratio,
so I'll look at that later.
So let's look at ratio.
Uh, let's see.
We're converting ABS over here.
I'm just scanning real quick
to see what's happening.
Um, some discussion between uh
contributors Misco and Sam about
what safe ADX is trying to do.
I'll look at that.
OK, so this looks like a
fairly one to one conversion,
but the diff is looking
somewhat horrible because, um,
the diff algorithm is picking up the
empty lines that used to be between
the struct specializations and
isn't matching them up to the empty
lines that are within the function.
That makes things actually
pretty hard to read.
The rest of it is OK to read,
so I'm thinking even though
I don't usually like it,
I'll switch to split view.
I don't think hiding white space will help.
OK, this is hopefully a bit more readable.
OK, let me minimize this.
OK.
Let me Scroll down,
look at this real quick.
OK, yeah, this is, um, easier to follow.
Uh, because we don't need
to look at 2 interleaved,
vastly different implementations.
OK, so now I want to verify, uh,
looking at the old code in the
new code that all of the behavior
is being preserved and that we're
not losing any special cases like
what about overflow and so forth.
Let's say, oh,
I can answer questions from Cameron,
he's asking.
I assume that the still doesn't
care about cling CL supporting the
standard mode of stood supposed 11.
That is correct.
So the we support the claim compiler
which actually ships in Visual Studio.
An optional thing you can select in
the installer as a first class citizen,
meaning that we support it for
both the compile time and codegen,
and we tried to support as much as
possible subject only to you know,
the features that it supports
itself in the compiler.
Sometimes we even support
it better than MSVC itself,
it depends who implements
core language features first.
However,
our STL considers MSVC's standard
modes as a minimum, so.
With the MSVC compiler stood,
C-14 actually means C-14 plus all
the C-17 stuff we had implemented at
the time that we implemented standard
mode options in the 1st place,
which I believe was VS 2015 update 3,
if I've got that correctly.
We do not have support in MSVC or in
our STL for ACS Plus 11 only mode.
We will support down level disc plus 14,
but as far as we're concerned
that's where time began.
So although the client compiler itself
supports AC plus 11 only mode RTL,
the Microsoft STL does not make
any attempt to support that.
So yeah,
so you'll see some things here
as camera noticed um,
that are not allowed in CS plus 11 only code.
I,
I for 1:00 AM very glad that we
have C + 14 has a minimum because
going back to C + C + 11 would
make constexpr very difficult.
If I ruled the world,
I would make you know 6 + 17 or 20,
the minimum.
But there are good reasons why we
have support down to C + 14 so that
customers can continue compiler and
your code without major changes.
Uh, OK, so let's take a look at this.
Um, first we have the UM simple struct ABS,
which is an absolute value at compile time.
All this stuff works with the type
def from C student or student dot H
int Max T That's the maximum integer
width in our implementation is just 64 bit,
so it's actually the same as long long.
But ratio is specified in terms of impact,
so that's what we use everywhere here.
So the input is in maxval,
so in the constexpr function land.
Uh, let's see none of this is template yet.
Um.
Template I I go through a mental list
of all the decorators we now functions.
Template now template.
Static doesn't need to be static.
Inline constexpr strictly more powerful,
so we do want constexpr.
Explicit is only for constructors
and definitely not virtual.
That's for member functions.
That's all good, we use no discard and
all return types of pure computation.
Not super consistently in old code,
but in new code we try to
be disciplined about this,
so that's why we've got no discard there.
That's good. We return in Max T.
Because that's the output,
so that corresponds here.
Um, the function we're going to
use the name under score ABS,
I believe that's OK certainly we had
no concerns about under score ABS
shadowing other stuff as a struct name,
so as a function should be fine,
and we're just converting it over.
There's also no one definition
rule concerns about converting
a struct into a function,
so I'm OK with that.
The input is a constant maxval.
We're not going to modify the
parameter in place, so adding cost
is absolutely the right thing to do.
The functions no,
except it's definitely not going.
Any exceptions, that's all good.
And then the return values here
evals less than zero, then negate it.
Otherwise return Val unchanged.
So exactly the same as what
the struct was doing. Great.
We're losing comment here.
Computes absolute value Val.
I'm totally fine about that.
I mean it's called abs.
Sort of self documenting.
This was our old policy of comment.
Literally everything here.
I believe it's obvious enough
that we don't need the comment.
So sounds good.
OK, next um.
So here are the struct is being preserved.
Um,
this is because safe malt is used by Chrono.
I can go find that control shift F
search for safe malt, not just in tests.
So safe malt is defined by ratio
and then it's used in ratio add.
And ratio multiply.
Uh, ratio multiply says um.
I do want to phenate,
meaning that we won't have a
numerator and denominator um.
Uh, or sorry, sorry, safe molt's ***.
Sphene.
Static asserts fine.
OK, yeah, these are true.
And then this one can detect
overflow during multiplication.
Yeah. I can't remember why we
passed through here actually.
Because this is the.
Yeah. I'd have to look up
exactly what we're doing here.
I'm not concerned for the purposes of this
PR since it's not changing this layer,
and this layer is necessary for
all the spine, like converting all
this to be constexpr wouldn't have.
A lot of value, yeah,
but that's why we're using a struct there.
OK, but we do need to convert this call.
So ABS ax value now just becomes
a plain call to ABX.
And because of the magic of constexpr,
we can call a constexpr function in
something like a default argument
to a function template and the
compiler will go evaluated for us.
So now looks good.
I'm currently we are not using constant eval,
um except when absolutely necessary because
compiler support is still in progress.
So even though in theory ABS here
could be defined as constant Val,
I'm much more comfortable
using just constexpr.
The difference is that constant
Val enforces that any call actually
be performed at compile time.
I mean is never emitted as a runtime call it.
So like if you're in Int main and
you call a constexpr function,
the compiler is totally allowed to just.
An ordinary call to it.
But if you call a constant eval function,
it actually doesn't need to boil
that down to a constant here,
because this is internal only,
we just only ever call it from
context for context.
So being constant Val wouldn't
really achieve anything.
It wouldn't, you know,
we could do it, but it wouldn't.
OK provide any optimization
benefits or anything.
So totally happy to see concepts for there.
And this just converting these
to function calls that's good
otherwise it's unchanged.
OK next we have a change to sign of
which is doing the same sort of thing.
Sign of Val was giving an int Max T
Now the interesting thing is here sign
of is returning either - 1 or one.
Not like a bull because we want
to do things like.
I think we here we compare and I
think we might actually multiply by
sine of elsewhere I'd need to go.
Find that good this morning I saw that.
I can check real quick.
But emitting uh, an IMAX TV?
That's not the right one.
under score sign of.
Yeah, we do multiply sine of times sine of,
so that's why it's in um, uh,
one or -, 1 rather than true or false.
OK, so again we have a notice card
function that's constexpr returns int Max
T under score sign of exact same name,
takes maxval also accept so same signature
and then this returns what we returning
before the values less than zero then -,
1 otherwise one.
Again, we're dropping the comment to
compute sine of Val that's in the function
name, so doesn't provide any value,
whereas the comments are being retained here.
Like computes ax times BX without overflow.
These are quite important because it
does say like what this thing is doing,
like what does safe mean and why is
this specialization being detected.
But for sign of the function name says
everything we need, so that's good.
Uh, OK, so now it's time to read this,
um, comment from Misco.
Misco says Safat X the stack,
asserting that it's valid.
So I think we should be able
to port it over to a function.
Um.
Sam asked,
wouldn't that make the expression nuts?
Fineable.
And then he asks, um,
if the signs of is different.
Yes, I agree because if you
wrote if constexpr here.
That would mandate all this
stuff via compile time,
and these are parameters,
so you can't actually do that.
Yeah, and then they then the parameters
would be non type template parameters
rather than just ordinary arguments.
We could phrase it like if bad condition
then do something like throw because a
a any attempt to throw an exception is
an error at compile time or call like.
Another technique we use is call a function
that is declared but not defined and
that will be an error at compile time.
But yeah, I'm not. I agree with Sam.
I don't see a lot of benefit to
trying to convert safe ad over um.
Also, this PR doesn't rule that out.
We could always do that in the future.
Um, here we use Safad.
Of this value, this value.
And the third one,
why do we have three values here?
Does this one? Oh no,
it's the second one is. Uh.
The nominator to ratio,
so we only give two values to safe mode.
That's right,
it's hard to keep in track with
all this double coin value stuff.
O safad.
This one computes if we would overflow.
It could be done, yeah,
with the throw technique basically
saying because the only call to
it is in a constexpr context,
so we would never worry about
like actually throwing in,
throwing an exception.
Yeah, I I think that could be
done later as an enhancement, um.
I like uh. I don't think anything
in this PR prevents that.
Yeah, it it's strictly optional.
Yeah, I will comment. Um, OK, let's comment.
I believe that it would
be possible. To convert.
Safe add to a constexpr function
but the. Um, overflow. Enforcement.
But I believe that the overflow enforcement.
Would be best expressed with.
If would overflow. Throw. Actually.
Um, I think we just typically call
a non constructs for function.
If would overflow um throw or
call a non constexpr. Function.
Which is a technique that
we've used elsewhere. Um.
The only usage of safe ad is at.
Compile. Time.
I could quote that if necessary.
Yeah, I want to do so.
That's ratio line 98.
So I'm going to bring up our repo.
Open up STL Inc go down to ratio.
I'd love to just be able to do
control P that'd be pretty cool.
Um, hit Y to get an absolute link,
go down to 98.
Here's the safe ad.
I'll get the context and I can copy this URL.
You can also right click
and copy permalink,
but I do it that way.
Uh, however. Um. I believe that
this could be done. As a separate
optional step after this PR.
I don't believe that it's critical to do now.
OK, how's that sound?
I believe there would be possible to
convert safe ad to a constexpr function,
but I believe that the overflow
enforcement would be best expressed
with if would overflow throw or
call a non constexpr function,
which is a technique that we
that we've used elsewhere.
The only usage of safe ad
is that compile time pal.
However, I believe that this could be done
as a separate optional step after this PR.
I don't believe that it's
critical to do now, OK.
OI think that looks good.
Yeah, trying to think, um.
I would prefer things to be incremental.
This is already changing.
Like, this is not a difficult change here.
It's not super scary.
Um, but it is changing code that
is used by ratio and Chrono.
I'm an existing code,
I'm in fact it's unconditional,
so it affects even C + 14.
So that makes me a little more
hesitant to just go wild and
change a whole bunch of stuff.
I'd rather be a little bit more incremental
here when we're writing completely new code.
That's leaf code that's not
used by an existing stuff.
Um, I think it's OK to be
a little bit more daring,
um and do things like,
you know, larger refactorings,
more aggressive changes here.
I think that doing sort of a
limited conversion of ABS sign of
and GCD is a good start and then
later we could continue converting.
It's sort of doing it from the leaf nodes up.
So I think that's fine.
OK, so here this is the usage of sign of.
So Safad is unchanged, still pass ANB,
but then instead of saying sign
a value not equal sign of value,
it's sign of a X not equal sine of BX.
That's good.
And then second Arg is parenthesized.
Yep, I can't.
Think we parenthesize because
of this angle bracket.
I think that's why we were concerned.
Interesting. We were very paranoid sometimes.
Um, if ABS.
Of X and you're making sure that
we're not flipping any variables.
That's good.
Less or equal it Max,
Max minus ABS of BX type.
OK, that looks to have been
completely converted over.
Do I believe that we still need
these parentheses here?
Plus,
SQL is a single token.
These parentheses are really not necessary,
but they were preexisting.
They were equally unnecessary here.
I'm not going to ask for them to be removed.
It's OK.
OK, next. OK, so now this
is the big change to GCD.
Here we had and this is one of the
reasons why it's a nice clean up.
Um. We had a public struct,
um that predigest predigested things
by taking their absolute value and
then passed it to this recursively
instantiating struct with a base case.
And then we had the we had an
explicit specialization down here,
um that absorbed 20 arguments,
which I found as I implemented the stuff I
believe that it was very convenient to have.
Even though technically math textbooks
say GC is 00 is not a thing, it's not one.
OK, so this is also going to be a notice
guard constexpr function returning it.
Next we're going to call under score GCD.
So saying name.
That's good, we're going to take ax and BX.
During Max's,
but they're not going to be confused
because we are going to modify them in place.
So that's good.
That is what allows.
It allows us to write this as a loop
rather than recursively calling.
So I like that it's going to be no except.
OK, so we're going to start
by absorbing this case,
which used to be a an explicit
specialization on the public function if.
X is equal to 0 and BX is equal to 0.
That's exactly this case.
Then we want to return one,
and we're going to preserve the comment,
contrary to mathematical convention,
avoids division by zero and ratio less good.
So if they're not both zero,
then we can take their absolute value.
That is what was happening here.
X is absolute of ax.
BX is absolute of X.
OK, so now we've done this,
and now we're going to use the.
GCD X helpers here, so this loop down
here should be equivalent to this.
So we're going to loop. Um.
This partial specialization
absorbed cases when BX was zero.
So while BX is not equal to zero,
we need to do work when it is equal to 0.
This would absorb it,
and we're just going to return a X return X.
So that is done.
We don't have the comment here.
Computes GCD of X and zero because that is,
you know, really obvious here.
I'm fine with not having that comment.
It was the contrary to mathematical
convention, one that was.
Very important.
Um.
Yeah, it also occurs to me that,
OK,
so we we are keeping this.
We don't need computers because
these are the internal ones.
Computes X and zero or ax and BX.
But we're losing this comment.
Computes GCD of absolute ax and absolute BX.
I think I would like to retain that because
that's an important thing that affects
the interface of this GCD function,
even though it's internal.
The fact that it takes the absolute
values um. I think we should,
we should retain that comment.
Uh, whoops.
I don't want to add that favor.
Um, here we go.
Copy.
Let's see. I think we
should preserve the comment.
Um, as it explains something
important about the behavior
slash interface of this function.
OK, I think we should preserve the
comment computer GCD of ABX, MBX.
Yep, there's still the names as it explains
something important about the behavior
slash interface with this function. OK.
But other than that, um, we have handled.
The 00 taking the absolute value. Umm.
When X is zero, we just return a X.
Otherwise we need to loop. OK, so here,
what was the loop doing when X is nonzero?
We sort of exchange things.
First we compute. OK, here, let's see.
Let's say I'm doing.
Store is constant Max T X2 is ax,
so store ax is a temporary.
Now assign ax equals BX,
so that puts BX here. Good.
And then BX is going to be the
original value of X, so X2.
Mod BX yes, this is good.
And there's no real convenient
way to do that better.
Uh, there's like food exchange,
but that would just make it harder to read.
Um, this is simple. I like it.
OK, that looks good.
And that's GCD.
Much easier to follow. Um,
rather than having a grand total of like 1/2,
is it four or 344 struct template,
either templates or specializations.
Now we just have a single
function with if statements.
Awesome.
Okay, ratio is now going to be uh,
changed to use it and we're even.
I'm not wrapping because we don't have
all these spammy double colon values.
As an aside,
we probably would have introduced
variable templates if we had them
when we originally wrote this code,
but we didn't,
so we had to use nested value
static context for data members.
But now we can just function call.
So static constexpr Max NUM is
NX times sine of DX times ABS
of X divided by GCD of NXX.
Yep,
that's all the same.
Instead of counts expert next den denominator
is ABS DX divided by GCD of NX DX perfect.
Here we have a GX that's the GCD a DX1DX2.
Yep.
And GX GY converted over two.
OK, so that's perfect.
And then let's take a look
at Chrono O Chrono.
Hadn't LCM least common multiple um.
Here we are losing the comment.
Compute LCM of AX and BX.
That's just the name of the thing,
so we don't need that comment here we
have a notice guard constexpr function
returning maxt named under score LCM.
Um, under score, capital LCM.
Uh, these can be constant Max DX,
constant Xbox.
No, except that's all good.
Then we're going to return.
OK, so we're going to return this here.
I'm just going to copy and search.
Uh, Nope, they're all.
It's because the double column value.
So if we converted.
Parans.
Yeah, OK, so converting double
cone value to parentheses,
it's the exact same expression.
Um, so no type is there.
I could have verified that visually,
but control F is sometimes easier.
OK, that's good.
This weird space is just
because of the wrapping here.
Is not actually in the code.
And then this GCD calls now function call.
Same with LCM.
LCM is still doing nontrivial work,
so there's no reason to try to lift that out.
OK, that looks great.
OK. So aside from the um.
The comment being lost.
The main question is do we need to
convert safe add over and I believe
that is definitely not necessary.
It's only correct as is.
It's not even really inconsistent
because currently safe multi still
expresses a structure that hooks deeply,
as we saw into the Chrono functionality.
UM, safe a DX or safe ad
only has the one caller.
Got this good also good
thing this is different.
Morally than the conversion
that's happening here.
We're converting the struct stuff
into context for functions,
but we don't need to handle error cases.
There's no errors that we're
trying to absorb.
This is error handling.
I think that doing that as a follow up
PR or filing an issue for something
like that is entirely reasonable.
I don't think it's necessary.
And if we did do it,
I think that we would simply need to
decide should it be calling a function.
Um, there is. I can also look at
precedents to add to this comment,
I think format had one example
where during contextual evaluation
we have a function like.
You see this because you violated
so and so yeah, here we go.
Inline void, you see this error
because our idea is out of range.
It's not constexpr or we do define it,
but it's not constant expert, so.
We call this function.
In context for evaluation,
when we want to, uh,
emit an error and the compiler will complain,
hey, this thing is in constexpr and the
name of the function is an indication.
This actually indicates that
we're sort of working around a
limitation in the core language.
It sure would be nice if we could
emit a custom error during context
for only as like a nice string.
We don't have that,
so this is a not awesome work around,
but it does work.
So I think I'll go ahead and quote this.
Because this is only used at compile time,
that's a format.
I'll just copy the name of the function.
OK, let's go load up the. Header.
I'm going to go back to format.
Go up a bit too far. Here we go.
Format. Hit Y for permalink,
search for function um copy definition.
And I can. Ohh it's pending good so I
can update it in place. Uh, let's see.
It would overflow.
I get the rid of the bit about throw.
We don't want that. Um,
calling on constexpr function and then,
which is a technique that
we've used elsewhere.
Here's the inline 1. Umm.
And then the calls OK this one.
This one's even better to
quote because I can show the
constexpr function pretty easily.
Like this?
How do I have two of these open?
Ohh this is the issue. OK.
OK, great.
OK, I believe there be possible to convert
safe add to contacts per function,
but I believe the overflow enforcement
would be best expressed with if would
overflow call an context function,
which is a technique we've used elsewhere.
In line void you see this error prone
Pran constexpr function that calls it.
The only usage is a compile time.
I believe it could be done
as a separate optional step.
I don't believe it's critical to do now.
OK. Yeah, the original function.
The original issue talked about
converting things over to um Constexpr,
but I see no reason to delay this PR.
For something that does not
deeply affect this existing code,
it can be done as a. Wow, this uh,
it's probably just in my remote desktop.
Um, surrendering looks a little messed up.
Um. I don't think you should delay this PR.
It can be done as a strictly
orthogonal separate step.
That won't change any of the existing code,
but then would further convert Safad
when we could look for additional
opportunities like is it possible to
convert somewhere all of safe molt?
Are there other uses that should be updated?
But I think this is a good first step and.
Is nice and self-contained and um.
Doesn't touch on the, the question of OK,
how exactly how do we enforce this?
Um, so I'm, I'm happy, I'm happy with this.
I'm going to update that comment.
Uh,
really the only thing is that that comment,
I can just go ahead and push that after this.
So I can go ahead and finish this review.
I'll just comment and I'll push
changes right after this.
OK. And yeah, that's the existing thing.
And Alex, who submitted the issues,
already approved, so he's happy with
the changes that are being made here.
Uh, OK, I think that's it for this PR's.
Are there any additional questions?
Let me look through the chat.
Casey agreed that the parentheses
seemed like overkill in LCM.
You know, if I got to push
changes for the extra comment,
I can push a removal of those parentheses.
I can go ahead and do that,
even though I didn't.
Get a comment for it. Yeah.
It's obviously not a huge issue but you know,
we try to avoid them when they're well
known precedence operators or and I
think pretty much everybody who took,
you know, algebra in elementary school,
most that multiplication
division of this president.
So yeah, in fact, I believe the
parentheses were guarding against.
The uh ohh wait,
you're talking about these parentheses?
Yes? Ohh no, I like these parentheses.
Um, so this is a special exception.
It is true that multiplication and
division have the same precedence,
and they're well known.
Evaluated left to right.
However,
it can be visually ambiguous if you
say um X / y * Z whether it was
intended for y * Z to group together.
It's certainly unambiguous according to the
rules of C Plus that you value left to right.
And I believe if you ask
a mathematician that yes,
it's also an ambiguous,
but many people just conventionally
will write X / y * Z,
and they do mean y * Z to
be grouped together.
So just to avoid any hint of,
you know, surprise.
This is the one case where I do
believe it's OK to have parentheses.
Uh, even though they're technically
not necessary.
Uh, it could also be expressed as BX.
Put that first and then.
The parentheses are, uh, not needed,
but actually there I think,
uh, we would want to.
Yeah, we want to avoid that.
We would still need parentheses.
We would want to avoid any overflow.
So I'm actually happy with
how this is written.
The parentheses I was thinking
of are where are they?
These ones here.
These parentheses are necessary
because they're protecting the less.
I believe they're protecting
the less equal um from being,
uh, parsed as like a start of a
template Arg list and safe add X.
But I don't think that was
ever an issue because it's less
equal and that's a whole token.
Even in the horrible days of C + O X,
when compilers were still implementing,
you know, all the rules for
nested angle brackets,
I think this was never ambiguous,
at least I I think this is
completely unnecessary.
That's why I was thinking, oh,
should I just remove those brands?
What do you think about those?
Should we get rid of those or.
Yeah, those two and OK,
that's that's preexisting.
It was there before. Weird, yeah,
which is why I didn't comment on it.
And if if there were no
other changes to push,
I would have just let it go because
it was definitely pre-existing.
It's not even that bad.
But if I got to push changes for the
comment that I do really want to keep,
May as well change this thing
that's like 2 lines away,
but here I think in the LCM.
Even though they are technically unnecessary,
I think this does warrant the parentheses,
which is probably why I wrote it that or
rewrote it that way in that first place.
I can't remember if I wrote
this or somebody else did,
but I like these ones.
OK. So I believe that's all the comments.
So I think that's it.
If you have any further questions,
feel free to leave them in
the comments on this video.
Otherwise, we'll see you next time.
Thanks for watching.